[Music]
incredible heat wave on the East Coast
you've been reading about this it's
miserable on the East Coast right now
yeah yeah they are so desperate for air
conditioning the that someone was
actually spotted going into a theater to
see Rock of Ages
he lasted 30 seconds oh you came running
out it's awful that's not what people
try the presidential campaign of course
this week a lot of people were saying
that the key of the presidential race is
the Hispanic vote that's been the big
story this year yes yeah Mitt Romney has
accused President Obama of pandering to
the Latino community he just said that
yeah the White House said the president
is unable to comment because he's busy
watching Telemundo and eating chalupas
I love Telemundo yeah of course Mitt
Romney also working hard to win the
Latino vote today
true story Mitt Romney tried to win over
a skeptical Hispanic audience in Florida
now unfortunately Romney set the wrong
tone when he came out and tossed the
crowd his car keys
[Music]
picking around it out I'll just pick
that up later didn't know what are you
done wrong mister just needs being
reported that story's on the internet
about Mitt Romney do not get a lot of
web traffic it's on the Internet and it
involves Mitt Romney people really don't
seem to care yeah
so today Romney solved the problem by
legally changing his name to milf Romney
I go them eight times today by accident
big Supreme Court decision yeah the
Supreme Court this is huge has decided
not not to find broadcast networks for
fleeting expletives or momentary nudity
yeah yes it looks like Wheel of Fortune
is about to get a lot more interesting
this is true though this changes our
business a lot yeah hey this late today
the Supreme Court ruled that TV networks
can show momentary nudity yeah so by
popular demand the view is now a radio
show
[Applause]
[Music]
my rocking chair listen you the whole
family yeah gather round gang
gather round 1920s family the views on
the raid y'all there's a new dating
website out there we heard about this
that helps match up people who look like
each other like that's something you
want right but it's true there's a
website that will match you up with
someone who looks like you that explains
why tonight I have a very hot date with
this police officer from Chagrin Falls
Ohio any time up here
[Applause]
with this foot screen here to see there
we go
[Applause]
I'm tanning yeah Tanny lady cop way to
go all right thanks Andy and cuffs you
know yeah this is a weird story this
just came out today it's being reported
that Kim Kardashian's mother was the one
who ordered her to make the sex tape
that made her famous her mom yeah
she said if Kim didn't do it she was
gonna get a spanking and if she did do
it she was gonna get a spanking that was
stupid
as opposed to the others this is a weird
one the Octomom has been hired as a
spokesperson for a service that lends
money that's true for a company lends
money yeah
they chose the optimum because their
slogan is there's no hole too deep to
climb out
[Music]
you